what I want to do in this video is talk
a little bit about the curly arrow
conventions used in organic chemistry
and the slight variations that I use in
many of the videos here on Khan Academy
so there's two types of curly arrows you
will see you will see a curly full arrow
like this so curly full arrow like this
and I made sure to draw it curly you
will always see them curly like this and
you'll see a curly half arrow that looks
like this so curly half-hour or fish
hook arrow so the convention is a fuller
or kind of a typical arrow that used to
seeing this is talking about the
movement of pairs of electron pairs
movement of pairs is the convention and
I'll show you in a second that I do a
slight variation of that and I do that
because it helps me account for
electrons and it helps me at least
visualize or conceptualize how things
are essentially but how things are
happening a little bit better but the
general convention is that this is
movement of pairs and this is movement
of electron by itself so electron
electron not part electron electron by
itself maybe I'll write it this way by
by itself and the full arrow is what
you're going to see through most of most
of organic chemistry so this is the one
that you're going to see most typically
the movement of pairs the movement of
electrons by itself this is going to
show up more in free radical reactions
which we do do but this is this is later
on and it's not and most of organic
chemistry is going to be dealing with
the movement of pairs now what I've
drawn over here is a curly arrow showing
the same thing happening and I'm showing
you the slight variation that I do and I
do it because it helps me once again
account for the electrons and it helps
me conceptualize what is going on so the
typical way that this type of the rate
this type of mechanism will be shown is
I'll say okay you have this electron
pair on this oxygen and this electron
pair sometimes will be say and you will
learn about this
not too long is going to the carbon or I
guess you could say it's attacking the
carbon right over here now the reason
why this I find a little bit less
intuitive is that the whole pair is not
going to the carbon that the oxygen is
still going to is still going to
maintain half of this pair and it's
going to form a bond essentially one end
of this pair is going to end up at the
carbon one end of this pair is going to
end up at the oxygen and they are going
to form a bond so the way I draw it
still drawing the full arrow so I'm here
I'm not I'm still talking about pairs
but I'm talking about the movement of an
electron as part of a pair so that's
kind of the slight non-conventional
thing that I do with the full arrow so
movement so movement movement of
electron electron as part part of pair
the end I oftentimes draw the the back
of the arrow from that electron but it's
important to recognize that that that
electron is not moving by itself it's
just ending up on one side of a bond it
is moving as part of a pair and another
way to think about it is this electron
is going to be on the other side of the
bond and I also want to be clear again
when I talk about electrons at either
side of bonds I like to think about that
because it helps me do it for for
accounting purposes but we know that
these covalent bonds these one electron
just doesn't sit on one side of the bond
and the other electron doesn't just sit
on the other side of the bond in fact
everything we do in organic chemistry
isn't anywhere near as clean as the way
we redraw it but I do this just to
remind myself that there are two
electrons here and when you have a bond
there is some probability that one of
the electrons is closer to the hydrogen
and there's some probability that that
electron is closer to the carbon and so
you can kind of imagine that the that
there that there are electrons on either
sides of the bond the actual reality is
that there's a blur of them and
depending on which which molecule is
more electronegative the probability
blur is a little bit more weighted on
one side or another but of course we
like to clean things up with these
formalisms right over here and this so
this is kind of the example when you
have this attacking pair
like to think of that the full arrow as
the movement of an electron is part of a
pair and then this breaking bond right
over here is another example so in the
typical convention you have this bond
here and remember a bond is made up of
two this covalent bond right over here
is made up of two electrons and if they
wanted to show this bond breaking and
both of these electrons going to this
bromine the convention is to kind of go
from the middle of the bond to the
bromine that I've never found that
intuitive because here once again here
once again bromine RT essentially had
part of the bond it was already on one
end of the bond so I like to visualize
that it's getting the other electron
that it wasn't that what it was not that
it's now getting both electrons one you
know one part of the bond was already
closer to the bromine now it's getting
the other it's the other part of the
bond so we're going to use full arrows
for these mechanisms just as we would
typically use full arrows but I'll often
conceptualize it as the movement of an
electron as part of a pair as opposed to
the entire pair but the full arrows are
still used the way it would be
conventionally used later on when we do
free radical reactions we're going to
talk about electron moving by itself so
notice this electron right over here
it's moving or it's going to it's doing
something it's not part of a pair it's
not part of a parrot's by itself so we
use the fish hook arrows right over here
we see a bond breaking but instead of
both electrons going to one of them
going to one of the atoms or another one
of the atoms is right over here so when
both electrons went to one of the atoms
we use the full arrow this already you
can kind of say had one and now it's
gaining another one so use a full arrow
but here the bond is breaking and each
electron is going to a different atom so
once again the electron is moving the
electron is moving by itself maybe I put
this right moving moving by itself and
here's a movement of the electron as
part of a pair so hopefully that
clarifies it a little bit this and it's
important to keep in mind a lot of the
notation I use as a departure from the
traditional organic chemistry notation
but I think at least in my mind it's
helped me build more of an intuition of
what's going on in the mechanisms and
account
for the electrons if you're at a if
you're in a course and and especially if
you know depending on how its graded you
might want to stick to whatever the
professor uses which is probably going
to be a little bit closer to the the
using the full arrow as the whole pair
and kind of going from the middle of the
bonds in the middle of the pair's as
opposed for one of the electrons moving
as part of the pair